la réalité c'est que la france comme de
très nombreux autres pays européens ne
peuvent plus emprunter seul et donc
c'est aussi là où les frigos ou ceux qui
étaient un peu plus près de leurs sous
ça dépend comment on voit la chose était
un peu reluctant c'est-à-dire qu'ils
disaient écoutez nous on a fait toutes
les réformes structurelles dans nos pays
pour justement limiter les déficits
publics voire faire des bénéfices à la
fin de l'année a fait faire des
excédents budgétaires alors que on va
devoir créer mutualiser une dette pour
des pays qui n'ont fait aucun de ses
efforts et en cela c'est aussi pour ça
qu'il manuel macron été aussi affaiblie
lors de ce conseil européen c'est à dire
qu emmanuel macron a dû renier sur ce
plus de 100 milliards d'euros de
subventions par rapport à ce qui avait
été annoncé on est passé de 500 à 390
milliards et à côté de ça on a aussi un
président de la république qui est en
moins grande position de force pour
exprimer à l'ensemble de ses partenaires
bas que la france demande une
mutualisation des emprunts alors qu'on a
fait aucune réforme structurelle sur la
question des retraites sur la question
du temps de travail sur la question de
la baisse des déficits publics
et on comprend bien que dans ces cas là
comme les efforts n'ont pas été fait en
france c'est difficile d'aller voir les
autres pays qui eux ont fait les efforts
au détriment de certaines politiques
publiques pour dire maintenant bas c'est
à vous de payer pour rire puisque c'est
aussi le rôle de l'opposition de montrer
ce qu'il ya derrière les accords de la
majorité le souligner ces accords
historiques et fenomeno simplement de
rappeler qu' on va taper dans les
budgets qui était prévu pour la santé
dans le budget pluriannuel dans le cadre
pluriannuel de financement de l'union
européenne tout à parti sur la santé en
commun a disparu on va taper sur le
programme erasmus c'est à dire qu'il y
aura moins au final d'argent pour le
programme erasmus pour les étudiants
européens puisque on va le réinjecter
ailleurs et que au final qu'est ce qu'on
est en train de faire vous pensez que
c'est une avancée pour l'europe moi je
peux émettre des doutes parce que on est
en train de mutualiser une dette donc on
va devoir lever de l'impôt européen
on veut dire qu'on est en train de
déposséder progressivement la raison
d'être du parlement national est en tout
cas de l'assemblée nationale c'est à
dire de voter l'impôt d'avoir le
consentement à l'impôt de la part des
français via leurs représentants c'est à
dire les députés et les sénateurs et je
pense qu'on fait un pas très en avant
vers une vera faire fédéralisme européen
et qu'on n'a pas forcément encore
accepté l'ensemble des enjeux qui sont
sous-jacents à cette création d'un
fédéralisme européen que certes vous
pouvez appelez de vos voeux mais moi je
trouve ça assez dangereux aujourd'hui de
le cacher et de le mettre sous le temps
dit un témoin